This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many of us share our homes with animals, Fari, Feathered, or Skeely. What is it, bad day? Yeah. We are definitely like my family members, headpets, and me. Yes, my right hand man. I got no kids, so that's my son.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们许多人都与动物同住一个屋檐下，无论是毛茸茸的、长羽毛的还是有鳞甲的。怎么了，今天过得不好吗？是的。我们绝对像我的家庭成员一样，摸摸头，还有我。是的，我的得力助手。我没有孩子，所以那就是我的儿子。
You know, he's my baby. Yet as much as we love our pets, our behavior toward animals can be paradoxical. Don't you think it's kind of weird that we're eating or cats me and we, you know, have strong beliefs and not eating me at this point? I think the more you love animals, the more you might consider being a vegetarian. It's the English bulldog was made by science. You know what I'm saying? Like, I think lizards and reptiles belong with mother nature. I don't think English bulldog is a part of other nature. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore the contradictions and of our relationships with animals. When Hal Herzog's son Adam was young, he had a pet mouse named Willy. One day Willy died.
你知道，他是我的宝贝。然而，尽管我们如此爱护宠物，我们对待动物的行为却可能是矛盾的。你不觉得奇怪吗，我们吃猫肉和我们，你知道，对于不吃肉有着坚定的信念？我认为你越是爱动物，你可能就越会考虑成为一名素食主义者。英国斗牛犬是科学制造的。你知道我在说什么吗？比如，我认为蜥蜴和爬行动物属于大自然母亲。我认为英国斗牛犬不是大自然母亲的一部分。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨了我们与动物关系中的矛盾。当哈尔·赫尔佐格（Hal Herzog）的儿子亚当很小的时候，他有一只叫威利的宠物鼠。有一天，威利死了。
So Hal used this as a teaching moment. We thought it would be a good lesson for the kids in terms of understanding death To have a funeral for him after all, you know, he was a pet the kids really Really liked them and they were very upset when he died until we had a funeral We we got a little cardboard box and made a little casket We took him into the backyard. We buried him and we actually Had a little headstone for him. We got some we got some rocks and and actually had a little headstone farm. We got some rocks
所以哈尔把这当作一个教育时刻。我们认为对于孩子们来说，这是一个理解死亡的好机会，为它举行一场葬礼，毕竟，你知道，它是一只宠物，孩子们真的很喜欢它，当它死的时候他们非常难过，直到我们举行了葬礼，我们拿了一个小纸箱，做了一个小棺材，我们把它带到后院。我们埋葬了它，我们实际上为它立了一个小墓碑。我们弄了一些石头，实际上为它立了一个小墓碑。我们弄了一些石头
and made a little headstone farm. A couple of days later, Hal's wife found some mouse droppings in the kitchen and asked him to do something about it. Well my wife said, need Nick, in the idea that we would be sharing our house with little creatures scampering around that were mice, was not something that she could live with, so she asked me to kill the mouse. And I did. I went out and I bought a mouse trap. I put a little dab of peanut butter on it
做了一个小墓碑。几天后，哈尔的妻子在厨房里发现了一些老鼠屎，并要求他采取点行动。嗯，我妻子说，尼克，家里出现小动物跑来跑去（也就是老鼠）的想法是她无法接受的，所以她要求我把老鼠杀了。我照做了。我出去买了一个捕鼠器。我在上面放了一小团花生酱
and put it under the kitchen in the next morning. I got up and the mouse was dead. And of course you did what you always do with dead mice, which is you put it in a cardboard box and took it out in the back and gave it a funeral, right? No, I threw it in a cardboard box and took it out in the back and gave it a funeral, right? No. I threw it in the bushes. Two dead mice, two very different responses.
然后把它放在厨房下面，第二天早上我起来时，老鼠已经死了。当然，你对死老鼠做了你一贯的做法，那就是把它放进纸盒里带到后面给它办个葬礼，对吧？没有，我把它扔进纸盒里，带到后面给它办个葬礼，对吧？没有。我把它扔进灌木丛里。两只死老鼠，两种截然不同的反应。
They were in different psychological categories. One was a pet, which a lot of people, including us, sort of considered William Family member, he had a name, and the other was a pest. He was free-learning by stealing our cheese and generally being what mice do, that is to say a pest. So there is a completely different psychological relationship between Willie or Pat and the pest. Hal Herzog is a professor of psychology at Western Carolina University. He's been studying human animal interactions for more than 30 years. He writes about the contradictions in our attitudes towards mice and other creatures.
它们属于不同的心理类别。一只是宠物，很多人（包括我们）都认为威利是家庭成员，它有名字；而另一只是害虫。它自由自在地偷我们的奶酪，表现得就像老鼠一贯那样，也就是害虫。因此，威利（宠物）和害虫之间存在着完全不同的心理关系。哈尔·赫尔佐格是西卡罗莱纳大学的心理学教授。他研究人与动物的互动已有30多年。他撰写了关于我们对老鼠和其他生物的态度中存在的矛盾的文章。
In his book, some we love, some we hate, some we eat. Why it's so hard to think straight about animals. I asked him how the labels we place on animals, good mouse, bad mouse, pet or pest. Change how we interact with them. Certainly one of the deepest and most important reasons that we treat animals differently is related to the categories that we put in. That's absolutely true.
在他的书《我们爱谁、恨谁、吃谁：为什么理清对动物的想法如此艰难》中。我问他，我们贴在动物身上的标签（好老鼠、坏老鼠、宠物还是害虫）如何改变我们与它们的互动方式。当然，我们对待动物会有所不同的最深层、最重要的原因之一，与我们赋予它们的分类有关。这绝对是真的。
So here's a second story that also lays out a slightly related but different contradiction. Your family once also owned a pet snake and a nasty rumor spread about what you were feeding the snake. What was the rumor and what is that reveal in some ways about the relationship we have with animals? I got a call one day from a friend of mine who's an animal rights activist
所以这里有第二个故事，它也展现了一个略微相关但又不同的矛盾。你的家庭曾经也养过一条宠物蛇，关于你喂蛇吃什么，曾流传过一个讨厌的谣言。那个谣言是什么？在某种程度上，这揭示了我们与动物之间的什么关系？有一天我接到一个朋友的电话，她是一位动物权利活动家
and she said that she had gotten a call from one of her friends saying that I was going to our local animal shelter and getting kittens and taking him home and feeding him to our bulk instructor who was like Willie a pet and had a name. Sam, what is this reveal about some of the contradictions we have about animals? You talk a little bit in the book about both the aborance with which we receive this idea that anyone would dream of feeding kittens to snakes. But of course, in your mind, there's also produced something of a thought experiment and some questions about cats and snakes. It did, and actually, for the next couple of days, there was something that kept nagging
她说她接到一个朋友的电话，说我要去当地的动物收容所领养小猫，然后带回家喂给我们的蟒蛇吃。那条蟒蛇就像威利一样是一只宠物，也有名字。山姆，这说明了我们对动物有哪些矛盾？你在书中谈到了我们对“任何人会梦想把小猫喂给蛇”这种想法所感到的厌恶。但当然，在你的脑海中，这也产生了一种思想实验，以及关于猫和蛇的一些问题。确实如此，事实上，在接下来的几天里，有件事一直萦绕在我
me about that. I was thinking like, okay, what Sam ate, he was a carnivore like cats, and what he ate was mice. I would go basically to the pet shop and buy mice to feed to the snake. Live mice, and I would kill the mice and give them to the snake. I thought, well, wait a minute. There's cats being euthanized at the animal shelter that are unwanted. Wouldn't it be more ethical for me to actually go to the animal shelter and get the bodies of dead kittens, as opposed to using buying live mice? Wouldn't that be morally permissible? Wouldn't it be morally better to actually feed kittens to
心头。我在想，好吧，山姆吃的是什么，它和猫一样是食肉动物，它吃的是老鼠。我基本上会去宠物店买老鼠来喂蛇。活老鼠，我会把老鼠弄死然后喂给蛇。我想，等等。动物收容所有些不想要的猫正在被安乐死。我去动物收容所拿死小猫的尸体，而不是去买活老鼠，这样不是更符合伦理吗？这难道不是道德上允许的吗？把小猫喂给
boa constrictors than to feed mice to boa constrictors? And of course, then, that means you went out to the animal shelter and did what the rumor was saying that you were doing. Of course I did not. We were out of pet cat at the time. We still have a pet cat. We live with cats. I love cats. I would never feed a cat to a boa constrictor.
蟒蛇，难道不比把老鼠喂给蟒蛇在道德上更好吗？当然，这意味着你去了动物收容所，做了谣言里说你在做的事。我当然没有。我们当时养了一只宠物猫。我们现在还有一只宠物猫。我们和猫住在一起。我爱猫。我绝不会把猫喂给蟒蛇。
So this was a classic example of head versus heart. And I realized that moral consistency often times leads us to stray in our interactions with animals. And that really haunted me ever since. Like, how could I live in a world in which it was okay to feed kittens and devolk constrictors? An interesting, Shack, or the original title of my book was feeding kittens to devolk constrictors.
所以这是理智与情感冲突的一个经典例子。我意识到，道德上的一致性往往会让我们在与动物的互动中误入歧途。这件事从那以后一直萦绕在我心头。比如，我怎么能生活在一个把小猫喂给蟒蛇是可以接受的世界里？有趣的是，尚卡尔，我这本书最初的书名就是《把小猫喂给蟒蛇》。
But the editor of my agent immediately made me change it because they said nobody would buy a book with that title. It sounds like the start of a bad-core and brothers movie. It does, and it snagged me a literary agent, but they wouldn't, they wouldn't, they wouldn't take the next step. Tell me about another story that you described in the book. This guy, Jim Thompson, he's a doctoral student you met, and he owned this very beautiful bird.
但我的经纪人编辑立刻让我改掉，因为他们说没有人会买一本这个书名的书。听起来像是一部粗俗的科恩兄弟电影的开端。确实如此，它帮我签下了一位文学经纪人，但他们就是不肯迈出下一步。跟我讲讲你在书中描述的另一个故事。这个叫吉姆·汤普森的人，他是你认识的一名博士生，他养了一只非常漂亮的鸟。
And he started thinking about that bird, and then he did something unusual with this bird. Walk me through what he did. Yeah. He was a graduate student, and he was a very logical, rational, rational person. And he had a pet bird as he cockatilla, as I recall, that he really loved. And his mother had given him a copy of an animal rights magazine.
他开始思考那只鸟，然后他对这只鸟做了一件不寻常的事。带我了解一下他做了什么。是的。他是一名研究生，是一个非常逻辑、理性的人。他养了一只宠物鸟，如果我没记错的话是一只鸡尾鹦鹉，他非常喜欢它。他母亲曾送给他一本动物权利杂志的复印件。
I think it was animal as a gender at the time. And he read the magazine. It changed his life. So he became an animal rights activist. Hardcore became a vegan, quit wearing leather, made his girlfriend start doing all that stuff as well. And then one day he looked at the bird who lived in a cage, and he came to the conclusion, the intellectual conclusion, that it was unethical to live with a bird in a cage. And so he took the bird outside and he freed it. And the bird flew out of the cage and he said it was an amazing sight to see that bird took off. And then he told me, he looked at me and said cheaply, you know, I know she probably died. I know that I was doing it more for me
我想当时那本杂志叫《动物议程》。他读了那本杂志。这改变了他的生活。于是他成为了一名动物权利活动家。彻底变成了素食主义者，不再穿皮革制品，还让他的女朋友也开始做所有这些事情。然后有一天，他看着那只住在笼子里的鸟，得出一个知识上的结论：和一只关在笼子里的鸟生活在一起是不道德的。于是他把鸟带到室外并放生了。鸟儿飞出了笼子，他说看到那只鸟腾空而起是一个令人惊叹的景象。然后他告诉我，他看着我说：“其实，我知道它可能死了。我知道我这样做更多是为了我自己
than I was for the bird. And he recognized that about himself and yet he chose to go ahead and do it. So how do you explain that contradiction? It's the sort of contradiction that we see all the time in our relationships with animals. And that's why the field of anthosoology, the new science of human animal interactions, is so both intellectually and also psychologically fascinating because we all have to live with these contradictions. For example, he was addicted to horse racing. He was a statistician and he was addicted to horse racing.
而不是为了这鸟。”他意识到了这一点，但他还是选择这么做了。那你如何解释那个矛盾？这正是我们在与动物的关系中经常看到的矛盾。这就是为什么人兽共处学（研究人与动物互动的崭新科学）这个领域在智力上和心理上都如此迷人，因为我们所有人都必须带着这些矛盾生活。例如，他沉迷于赛马。他是一名统计员，并且沉迷于赛马。
When you came in animal rights activists, he said he was going to quit going to the track anymore. But every month he would feel this urge and he would go to the track. And then he told me that he would feel bad about it for weeks. You know, it made me think about all the ways in which we sort of relate to animals in some ways as if there was sort of fellow creatures. In other words, if we kept a fellow human being in a cage, it would seem absolutely unjust, immoral, and wrong, and releasing that person from the cage would seem like the only right
当他成为动物权利活动家时，他说他将不再去赛马场了。但每个月他都会感到这种冲动，然后他还是会去赛马场。然后他告诉我，为此他会感到内疚好几周。你知道，这让我想到了我们与动物交往的种种方式，在某些方面，就好像它们是我们的同类一样。换句话说，如果我们把同类人类关在笼子里，那将显得绝对不公正、不道德和错误，而将那个人从笼子里释放出来似乎是唯一正确的事情。
thing to do. And in some ways, we extend that logic when we talk about the bird. That's what he was doing. And as I was reading the story, it reminded me of another story you have in the book. This was a different story, but in some ways it has the same subtext. Cookie was a 12-foot-long Nile crocodile at the Miami Serpentarium. A six-year-old boy once fell into cookies and closure, and the croc did what crocodiles do, he grabbed the child, pulled him underwater,
在某种程度上，当我们谈论那只鸟时，我们延伸了这种逻辑。他当时就是这么做的。当我读到这个故事时，它让我想起了书中的另一个故事。这是一个不同的故事，但在某些方面它有相同的潜台词。库奇是迈阿密蛇类馆里一条12英尺长的尼罗河鳄鱼。一个六岁的小男孩曾经掉进了库奇的围栏里，而鳄鱼做了鳄鱼会做的事：它抓住了孩子，把他拉到了水下。
what did the owner of the Serpentarium do next? Well, immediately the owner of the Serpentarium jumped into, he heard the people watching, gasping horror, and he knew something was going on. He jumped into the cage and tried to save the kid, little David, and failed. And that night, Haas woke up in the middle of the night. I'm assuming he didn't get my sleep.
蛇类馆的主人接下来做了什么？嗯，蛇类馆的主人立刻跳了进去，他听到围观的人们发出惊恐的喘息声，他知道出事了。他跳进笼子里试图救那个孩子，小大卫，但失败了。那天晚上，哈斯在半夜醒来。我猜他没睡着。
He had a revolver, a luger in his bedroom. He put the shells in it, and he went into Cookie's cage, and he put nine bullets in his brain. And by the way, he had had Cookie for many, many years, and cookie was a favorite of his, and it was an animal that he loved in a way that probably only herpetologists, somebody like me, you know, who studies real tiles and likes them, you know, you know, can understand. I argue that in some ways it's the operation of a phenomena that cognitive psychologist called heuristics.
他的卧室里有一把左轮手枪，一把鲁格手枪。他把子弹装进枪里，走进了库奇的笼子，把九颗子弹射进了它的脑子里。顺便说一句，他养库奇很多很多年了，库奇是他的最爱，他以一种可能只有爬行动物学者（像我这样研究爬行动物并且喜欢它们的人）才能理解的方式深爱着这只动物。我认为，在某种程度上，这是一种被称为启发法的认知心理学现象在起作用。
Heuristic is sort of a mental shortcut and it sometimes leads to good, you know, logical, correct answers, but sometimes it doesn't. In this case, it seems to be the operation of a type of heuristic called the moral heuristic. And the moral heuristic is revenge. And at one point, the New York Times actually wrote an editorial about that event. And the editorial writer I think got it right and the editorial writer wrote, killing Cookie made no sense intellectually, but it felt right emotionally. And the reason it didn't make sense intellectually, of course, is the idea that a crocodile
启发法是一种心理捷径，它有时会引导得出好的、合乎逻辑的、正确的答案，但有时不会。在这种情况下，这似乎是一种被称为道德启发法的启发法在起作用。而道德启发法就是复仇。有一点，《纽约时报》甚至就那一事件写了一篇社论。我认为社论作者说得对，社论作者写道：杀死库奇在理智上毫无意义，但在情感上感觉是对的。它在理智上没有意义的原因，当然是这样一个观点：鳄鱼
would do what a crocodile does is hardly surprising. That's what crocodiles do. The brain is smaller than a walnut. He is a creature largely of instinct, particularly when it comes to food. And he was doing what crocodiles do. He was not a moral agent, which I would argue is one of the biggest differences between humans and other species. We are moral agents. So the interesting thing is that has the owner in some ways related to cookie as if cookie
做出鳄鱼会做的事一点也不奇怪。这就是鳄鱼所做的事。它的脑子比核桃还小。它主要是一个靠本能行事的生物，特别是在食物方面。它在做鳄鱼做的事。它不是一个道德主体，我认为这是人类与其他物种最大的区别之一。我们是道德主体。所以有趣的是，主人在某种程度上对待库奇的方式，就好像库奇
was a person, that cookie was a moral agent. And in some ways that's a variation of what Jim Thompson was doing with the bird, wasn't it, which is you're assuming that the animal has agency and behaves or things or has it? Which is, you're assuming that the animal has agency and behaves or things or has human-like qualities and that you're therefore obliged or required to treat this other creature as if in some ways it had human-like qualities. I'm sure that if you interviewed Haas,
是一个人，库奇是一个道德主体。在某种程度上，这正是吉姆·汤普森对那只鸟所做事情的变体，不是吗？也就是，你假设动物具有能动性，并且表现得像、或者思考得像、或者具有类人的特质，因此你就有义务或被要求将这个其他生物当作它在某些方面具有类人特质来对待。我确信，如果你采访哈斯，
he clearly would know the difference at an intellectual level between a crocodile and a person. But you're quite right. He's basically treated him the same way that we would a person. This similarly played out in a bizarre incident that happened in Tennessee, where an elephant named Mary killed its groom while in a circus parade in 1916. And they hung the elephant to death. And to me, that was the ultimate example of where we've anthropomorphized animals that we give it capital punishment in a sense, for something that it was clearly not morally
他在理智层面上显然知道鳄鱼和人之间的区别。但你完全说得对。他基本上对待它的方式就像我们对待人一样。这在田纳西州发生的一起离奇事件中也类似地上演了：1916年，在一次马戏团游行中，一头名叫玛丽的大象杀死了它的驯养员。他们把这头大象绞死了。对我来说，那是我们将动物拟人化的终极例子，从某种意义上说，我们对它处以死刑，而它做这件事显然不具道德
culpable. So people listening to these stories would say, wow, those are really crazy stories. But as you point out in the book, this tendency we have to anthropomorphize animals is actually really ubiquitous. You draw contrast between the way we relate to the giant panda and the giant salamander. Tell me what the giant salamander is, what it looks like, and how our attitudes to what these different animals are shaped by the ways in some ways that we anthropomorphize them. Yeah, so the animals in some way are similar, the giant panda and the giant Chinese salamander, and that they're both endangered and they both live in China,
上的罪责。所以听到这些故事的人会说，哇，那些真是疯狂的故事。但正如你在书中所指出的，我们这种将动物拟人化的倾向实际上非常普遍。你对比了我们与大熊猫和大鲵的关系。告诉我大鲵是什么，它长什么样，以及我们对这些不同动物的态度是如何在某种程度上由我们拟人化它们的方式塑造的。是的，所以这些动物在某些方面是相似的，大熊猫和中国大鲵，它们都是濒危动物，都生活在中国，
and they're both really special, although in quite different ways. The giant Chinese salamander is basically a six-foot-long bag of brown slime with beady eyes. And to me, they're like, they're striking. I wouldn't say that they're beautiful, but they're stunning just in their size and they're, I don't know, to me, they're charismatic, but I don't think most people would agree with that. But you're not gonna see the world wildlife fun,
而且它们都非常特别，尽管方式很不相同。中国大鲵基本上是一个六英尺长的、长着小圆眼睛的棕色黏液袋。对我来说，它们很引人注目。我不会说它们很漂亮，但仅就它们的体型而言，它们是惊艳的，而且我不知道，对我来说，它们很有魅力，但我认为大多数人不会同意这一点。但是你看不到世界野生动物基金会
putting a picture of the giant Chinese salamander on their logo instead They use the panda and the panda you know in some ways looks a little bit like a human But it's basically a faker and the sense that it has these Giant circles around its eyes Which ethylogic is called baby releases so we look at that panda and it basically Logs on to that jams into that that maternal instinct that we have when we see creatures with that panda and it basically logs on to that, jams into that maternal instinct that we have when we see creatures with big eyes and it impose on them that in some ways
把中国大鲵的照片放在他们的标志上，相反他们用的是大熊猫。大熊猫在某种程度上看起来有点像人类，但它基本上是个冒牌货，因为它有这些巨大的黑眼圈，在动物行为学中这被称为婴儿释放机制。所以我们看着那大熊猫，它基本上就锁定了、触发了我们看到大眼睛生物时拥有的那种母性本能，并将它们强加给我们，在某种程度上
it reminds us of a human infant. So for example, research has shown that one of the biggest predictors of whether or not people will give money to save animals is the size of the animal's eyes and pandas certainly have it when it comes to eye size. When we come back, do our pets actually improve our lives? Pet owners, we're better off in terms of their psychological and physical health and non-pet owners, but so are people with Mercedes-Benzis. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
它让我们想起人类婴儿。例如，研究表明，人们是否会捐钱拯救动物的最大预测因素之一就是动物眼睛的大小，而大熊猫在眼睛大小方面当然符合这一点。稍后回来，我们的宠物真的能改善我们的生活吗？宠物主人在心理和身体健康方面比非宠物主人过得更好，但开梅赛德斯-奔驰的人也是如此。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When we think about pets in the United States, we often picture cats, dogs, maybe a hamster. But how Herzog says our relationship with animals, especially those we consider pets, is largely dictated by our communities and culture. So, for example, I've got a friend that's an anthropologist who was born and raised in Kenya. And in the village where he was raised, they kept dogs. The dogs were allowed to roam freely in the village.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当我们想到美国的宠物时，我们通常会想到猫、狗，也许还有仓鼠。但哈尔·赫尔佐格说，我们与动物的关系，尤其是那些我们认为是宠物的动物，在很大程度上是由我们的社区和文化决定的。所以，举个例子，我有一个朋友是一位人类学家，他在肯尼亚出生长大。在他长大的村子里，他们养狗。狗被允许在村里自由漫游。
They really liked dogs that we would consider mean dogs because they scared away animals and they scared away strangers. But they were considered pets. In fact, in his language, they don't even have a word for pet. And I went to ask him, I said, Naga, would you let a dog in your house living in Africa? And he said, no. I said, would you let a dog eat at the table? And you know, feed them some table scraps.
他们真的很喜欢我们认为是凶恶的狗，因为它们能吓跑动物和陌生人。但它们被视为宠物。事实上，在他的语言里，他们甚至没有“宠物”这个词。我去问他，我说，纳加，你会让狗进你在非洲的房子吗？他说，不。我说，你会让狗在桌旁吃饭吗？
He said, no. I said, Naga, would you let a dog eat at the table, you know, and you know, feed them some tables, perhaps? He said, no, I said, no, go, do you really let a dog sleep in your bed? And then look at the horror on his face. It was like, if I said, hey, I got this really cool rat. I just caught down it. It's the river. You want to sleep with it tonight? And in fact, I recently got some new data on this. So it turns out that in the United States States we have amongst the highest rate of dog ownership
（你知道的，喂它们一些餐桌上的残羹剩饭。）他说，不。我说，纳加，你会让狗在桌旁吃饭吗，你知道的，喂它们一些餐桌残羹剩饭？他说，不。我说，纳加，你真的会让狗睡在你的床上吗？然后看着他脸上的惊恐神情。那表情就像我说：“嘿，我有一只超酷的老鼠，我刚在河里抓到的。你今晚想跟它一起睡吗？”事实上，我最近得到了一些关于这方面的新数据。结果表明，在美国，我们拥有
in the world. And there are enormous differences between countries in dog ownership. So there's about 250 dogs per thousand people in the United States. In Egypt there's about five dogs per thousand people. So these cultural variations and what people, you know, what's except the walls of pet and what's not is just huge. I want to spend a moment talking about the relationships that we have with pets in North America. I know that people spend a lot of money on pets, but as I read your book, I was just shocked at how high that number is. How much do we spend on our pets every year, how?
世界上最高的养狗率之一。不同国家之间的养狗率存在巨大差异。所以在美国，大约每千人拥有250只狗。在埃及，大约每千人拥有5只狗。因此，对于什么是宠物、什么不是宠物，人们在文化上的差异和认可度是巨大的。我想花点时间谈谈我们在北美与宠物的关系。我知道人们在宠物上花了很多钱，但当我读你的书时，我只是对这个数字之高感到震惊。我们每年在宠物上花多少钱，哈尔？
It's pushing about $80 billion a year right now. It's an enormous amount of money. I mean, that's a fleet of aircraft carriers. Yeah, yeah, it is. And if you, even adjusted for inflation, the amount of money that we spend on pets each year in the United States has more than doubled in the last 30 years per capita. The real increase in spending has been at the high end.
现在正逼近每年约800亿美元。这是一笔巨额资金。我的意思是，那是一支航空母舰舰队。是的，是的，确实如此。而且如果你将通货膨胀考虑在内，美国人每年花在宠物身上的资金在过去30年里按人均计算已经翻了一番多。实际支出的增长主要集中在高端市场。
Gourmet pet food for dogs. You can buy food that you would eat. In fact, I tease my wife and I say, what we're going to do is we get ready for the giant decline. We're going to stack up on dog food and when the hurricane comes. But it's also things like, you know, pet daycares, pet spas. There's a hotel that has a zin room. You can get your pets a massage and I don't know what else pets do in a zin room.
狗狗的美食宠物食品。你可以买到连你自己都会吃的食物。事实上，我取笑我的妻子说，我们要做的就是在大衰退来临时，囤积狗粮，等飓风来临时吃。但这也包括诸如宠物日托、宠物水疗。有一家酒店设有禅意房间。你可以给你的宠物做按摩，我不知道宠物在禅意房间里还能做别的什么。
We're talking about dog parks. We're talking about jewel columns. We're talking about pet fashion weeks. We're talking about all these things and the pet food industry You know calls this the humanization of pets and it really has taken off in the last 30 years And what do you think is happening psychologically here? Well, you know people in some ways are perhaps investing more in their pets than they're investing in their fellow human beings Maybe even their fellow family members. Yeah, it's interesting
我们谈论的是狗公园。我们谈论的是珠宝项圈。我们谈论的是宠物时装周。我们谈论所有这些事情，宠物食品行业（你知道的）称之为宠物的拟人化，它在过去30年里确实腾飞了。你认为这里在心理上发生了什么？嗯，人们在某种程度上可能在宠物身上投资更多，超过了他们在同胞人类身上投资的，甚至可能是他们的家庭成员。是的，很有趣
I've thought about that a lot and I think it's partially due to demographic trends. One of the things that we know is that there's a paradox, many paradoxes in our relationships with animals, one of them is who's most in love with their pets. So it turns out that people living alone tend to be most attached to their pets. However, they also have, they're less likely to have a pet. And so people that are least attached to their pets tend to be adults with children in their family. But they're most likely to be living with the pet because they get pets for the kids. Once the kids leave, they get rid of the pets. So what happens is people living alone are more attached to their pets.
我对此思考了很多，我认为这部分是由于人口统计趋势。我们所知道的一件事是，存在着一个悖论，我们与动物的关系中存在许多悖论，其中之一就是谁最爱他们的宠物。结果证明，独居的人往往对他们的宠物最依恋。然而，他们也拥有，他们养宠物的可能性更小。因此，对宠物最不依恋的人往往是有孩子的成年家庭。但他们最有可能与宠物生活在一起，因为他们为了孩子而养宠物。一旦孩子离开，他们就会摆脱宠物。所以发生的情况是，独居的人对他们的宠物更加依恋。
And what we know is that there's now more people living alone. People are getting married later, if they're getting married at all. They're living longer after the kids leave. And there's a number of trends. And so there's more people living alone. And these people tend to be more attached to their pets. Another factor is advertising and publicity by the pet products industry
我们所知道的是，现在独居的人更多了。人们结婚的时间越来越晚，如果他们还会结婚的话。他们在孩子离开后活得更久。还有许多其他趋势。因此，独居的人更多了。这些人往往对他们的宠物更依恋。另一个因素是宠物用品行业的广告和宣传，它们推销这样一种观念：宠物对人有益，如果你养一只宠物，你将成为一个更快乐、更健康的人。养宠物真的对你的健康和长寿有益吗？
that push the idea that pets are good for people, that if you get a pet, you will be a happier and healthier person. Is this actually true that owning a pet is good for your health and your longevity? We have overwhelming evidence now that for a lot of people interacting with their pet does have short-term effects on their physiology, lowers their stress,
我们现在有压倒性的证据表明，对许多人来说，与宠物互动确实会对他们的生理产生短期影响，降低他们的压力，让他们感觉更好。然而，你问的问题是不同的。那是我们的宠物真的对我们的健康有益并让我们活得更久吗？在这里，我的回答是，我们没有特别好的证据证明宠物对人类健康的长期影响。
makes them feel better. The question you ask, however, was different. That was our pets really good for our health and make us live longer. And here my answer is that we don't have particularly good evidence for the long-term impact of pets on human health. I have a stack of reprints in my office, which people have found that people with pets, they sleep better, that they go to the doctor less, that they have better well-being, that they're less lonely, etc., etc., etc. But I have another stack of reprints in my office that says just the opposite, that people with pets are more lonely, that they're more likely to go to the doctor, that they're more likely to drink a lot, that they're more likely to have ulcers.
我的办公室里有一堆重印文献，人们发现养宠物的人睡得更好，看医生的次数更少，幸福感更高，不那么孤独，等等，等等，等等。但我的办公室里还有另一堆重印文献，说的恰恰相反，养宠物的人更孤独，他们去看医生的可能性更大，他们大量饮酒的可能性更大，他们患溃疡的可能性更大。
But you never hear about those studies in the news, they don't make the news. There's very little evidence that pets make people live longer. And one of the problems we have is which direction the causal arrow points. For example, recent study by the RAND Corporation found that pet owners, in fact, were better off in terms of their psychological and physical health and non-pet owners. But as they pointed out, so are people with Mercedes-Benzis. People with pets tend to be wealthier, they tend to be younger, they tend to live in nicer places. In other words, the socioeconomic factors may be that it's not that pets are making people
但你从未在新闻中听到过这些研究，它们没有上新闻。几乎没有证据表明宠物能让人类活得更久。我们面临的问题之一是因果箭头指向哪个方向。例如，兰德公司最近的一项研究发现，宠物 owners（主人）在心理和身体健康方面确实比非宠物主人过得更好。但正如他们所指出的，开梅赛德斯-奔驰的人也是如此。养宠物的人往往更富有，他们往往更年轻，他们往往住在更好的地方。换句话说，社会经济因素可能意味着，并不是宠物让人们
happier and healthier. It's that happier, healthier people are more likely to have pets. We have very little data to test those two different hypotheses. You present some really striking studies in the book, which talk in some ways of the downside of having pets you say that some eighty five thousand americans are injured each year according to the cdc because they trip over their pets or otherwise are injured by them and i understand your neighbor and is one of those uh... victims my neighbor and is one of those victims uh...
更快乐、更健康。而是更快乐、更健康的人更有可能养宠物。我们几乎没有数据来检验这两种不同的假设。你在书中提出了一些非常引人注目的研究，在某种程度上谈到了养宠物的缺点，你说根据疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）的数据，每年大约有八万五千名美国人因为被宠物绊倒或以其他方式受伤而受伤，据我所了解，你的邻居安就是其中一位受害者。我的邻居安就是其中一位受害者。
she's a classic case she was walking her dog and leash wrapped around her leg and she fell over and she broke her collarbone um I recently went on Facebook and I put a call out. I said, if any of you have ever been injured by a pet by walking your dog, let's say, please write me a note. And I could not believe the response. 80 people responded to me. Many of them were professionals in the field. Some of them even sent me their X-rays, which I, and I was, and some of these incidents were not trivial. Some of these incidents were life changing. So there are downsides to pet ownership.
她是典型案例。她遛狗时牵引绳缠在腿上，然后摔倒了，锁骨骨折了。嗯，我最近上了Facebook，发出了一个呼吁。我说，如果你们当中有人曾因为遛狗等原因被宠物伤害过，请给我写个便条。我简直不敢相信那个反响。80人回复了我。其中许多人是该领域的专业人士。有些人甚至把他们的X光片发给了我，而且，我当时，其中一些事件并非无足轻重。其中一些事件是改变人生的。所以养宠物是有缺点的。
So there's a new frontier in pet ownership now, and I want to play you a clip. This is from the company Sony, and they presented this account of a dog at a tag conference. Let's start with design. First, the obvious. Ibo is adorable. He wags his tail, wiggles his ears, blinks his eyes, and he even does that doggy smile. You know, that smile that dogs do when you scratch it just right and they kind of tilt their head and have close their eyes and they open their mouth
所以现在养宠物有一个新前沿，我想放一段音频给你听。这是索尼公司的一段录音，他们在某个技术大会上展示了这只狗。让我们从设计开始。首先，显而易见的是，爱宝（Aibo）非常可爱。它摇尾巴、扭动耳朵、眨眼睛，它甚至还会做出那种狗狗的微笑。你知道，当你在正确的地方挠它时，狗狗们会做出的那种微笑，它们会微微倾斜头部，闭上眼睛，稍微张开嘴巴
a little and smile. Yeah, that's fine. So of course, how IBO is in a real dog, IBO is a robot, and it really looks like humans are completely indiscriminate when it comes to who we will consider and what we will consider to be pets. Yeah, the thing about IBO, IBO has got an interesting history. Sony originally developed IBO and IBO is a robotic dog and it does all kind of things. It'll fetch, it'll signal you its emotions, it'll respond when you call its name. The problem with IBO is that it's metal and shiny,
笑一下。是的，挺好的。所以当然，爱宝不是一只真正的狗，爱宝是一个机器人，看起来人类在选择谁和什么可以被视为宠物方面完全是不加区分的。是的，关于爱宝，爱宝有一段有趣的历史。索尼最初开发了爱宝，爱宝是一只机器人狗，它能做各种各样的事情。它会捡东西，会向你发出情绪信号，当你叫它的名字时它会回应。爱宝的问题在于它是金属的、亮晶晶的，
so it doesn't have fur. So while Ibo had some real, it was expensive, it originally cost about 2000 bucks, it didn't catch on initially, but Ibo was recently resurrected by Sony. And I've looked at the new promotional videos of Ibo, and I'm ready, I'm about ready to get one. It looks pretty good. Oh, and there have been studies where they've taken IBO and some other types of robotic pets into things like nursing homes. And to see if they have the same impact on people living in nursing homes in terms of morale and well-being as they do a real dog. And the results have been sort of mixed.
所以它没有毛。因此，虽然爱宝有一些真实的，它很昂贵，最初售价约2000美元，它最初并没有流行起来，但爱宝最近被索尼复活了。我看了爱宝的新宣传视频，我已经准备好了，我差不多准备买一个了。看起来挺不错的。哦，并且有研究将爱宝和其他一些类型的机器人宠物带入疗养院等场所。看看它们在士气和幸福感方面是否对住在疗养院的人产生与真正的狗相同的影响。结果可以说是喜忧参半。
But some of the cases IBO has actually done better in some cases than an actual animal. And some of this I'm guessing might have to do with the fact that Ibo doesn't have some of the downsides that owning a real dog might have. Ibo is not going to bark uncontrollably at night or bark at your friends when they come over for a party. I mean dogs and cats and pets can sometimes induce stress within families and emotional and psychological problems within households. Absolutely, they can. The other thing that IBO doesn't do is raise the pesky ethical questions
但在某些情况下，爱宝实际上比真正的动物做得更好。我猜这其中有些原因可能与爱宝没有养真狗可能带来的一些缺点有关。爱宝不会在夜里无法控制地吠叫，也不会在你的朋友来开派对时对他们吠叫。我的意思是，猫狗和宠物有时会在家庭内部引发压力，并在家庭中引发情感和心理问题。绝对的，它们会的。爱宝不会做的另一件事是引发伴随养宠物而来的烦人的伦理问题。
that come with pet ownership. You don't have to worry about the ethics of the private IBO of a sex life by castrating them. You don't have to worry about the ethics of leaving IBO alone for long periods of time while you're at your office during the day. You don't have to worry about the ethics of leaving IBO alone for long periods of time while you're You're at your office during the day. You don't have to take IBO for a walk three times a day and then pick up poop as you Walk it walk it down the road. So I think I've got some real advantages There's been an explosion of research into pet ownership and in fact one of them actually looks at how Humans come to choose different pets the researchers Michael Roy and Nicholas Christianfeld took pictures of owners and dogs in dog parks to examine the important question of whether dogs and their owners tended to
你不必担心剥夺爱宝通过阉割过性生活的伦理问题。你不必担心白天在办公室时把爱宝独自留在家中很长时间的伦理问题。你不必担心白天在办公室时把爱宝独自留在家中很长时间的伦理问题。你不需要一天遛爱宝三次，然后在它沿着路走的时候去捡便便。所以我想爱宝有一些真正的优势。关于养宠物的研究呈爆炸式增长，事实上，其中一项研究实际上着眼于人类如何选择不同的宠物。研究人员迈克尔·罗伊（Michael Roy）和尼古拉斯·克里斯廷费尔德（Nicholas Christenfeld）拍摄了狗公园中主人和狗的照片，以探讨一个重要问题：狗和它们的主人是否倾向于
look alike. Walk me through the experiment, Helen. What did it find? Yeah, what they did was they took pictures of dogs and others in dog parks and then they showed these pictures to People that did not know the owners of the dogs and they asked them to match them up And they presented in sort of a 50-50 choice and they asked people which dog belongs to this owner which are these two dogs and If people did not look like their dogs you'd expect a 50-50 hit rate that simply random chance But they didn't find that.
长得相像。带我了解一下这个实验，哈尔。它发现了什么？是的，他们做的是拍摄了狗公园里狗和主人的照片，然后把这些照片给不认识这些狗的主人看，并要求他们进行配对。他们以一种50对50的选择呈现，并问人们哪只狗属于哪个主人，这两只狗中哪一个是……如果人们长得不像他们的狗，你会期望命中率为50-50，那纯粹是随机几率。但他们没有发现那个。
They found those between, as I recall, 65 and 70 percent of people correctly matched what people looked like, knowing nothing about the person with their dogs. Now, Shaker, I read that study and I'm just shaking my head, thinking, no way that this is true. However, there's now been at least three studies that have replicated this in different countries under different circumstances. So I've reluctantly become a believer.
他们发现，如果我没记错的话，在65%到70%之间的人，在对这个人一无所知的情况下，正确地将人们的长相与他们的狗匹配了起来。听着，尚卡尔，我读了那项研究，直摇着头想，这绝不可能。然而，现在至少有三项研究在不同的国家、不同的环境下复制了这一结果。所以我勉强成了一个信徒。
There is some tendency for people to look like their dogs. So besides the many animals that you own that we've already talked about, you also own a cat whose name is Tilly, and you have what other cat owners might think is a rather idiosyncratic way of expressing your affection for Tilly. In the book you write, don't feel bad, Tilly. I love you, even if you are a socially constructed parasite.
人们确实有长得像他们狗的某种倾向。所以除了我们已经讨论过的你拥有的许多动物外，你还养了一只名叫蒂莉（Tilly）的猫，并且你对蒂莉表达喜爱的方式，在其他猫主人看来可能是相当独特的。你在书中写道：“别难过，蒂莉。我爱妳，即使妳是一个社会构建的寄生虫。”
Really? Yeah, the these questions, she a parasite. And this is the view that pets are basically a form of evolutionarily, what's called nests parasitism, which we see in birds. So for example, let's take the cow bird. What a cow bird does is it lays its eggs and another bird's nest.
真的吗？是的，这些问题，她是寄生虫。这就是这样的观点：宠物基本上是演化上的一种形式，被称为巢寄生，我们在鸟类中可以看到这一点。例如，我们以牛鹂为例。牛鹂所做的是它把蛋下在另一只鸟的巢里。
Let's say a rins nest. And it then flies away and leaves its eggs for this rind to hatch. The rind then sits on the egg until it hatches and so that the rind winds up raising the bird, the baby of another species. And that's what happened, that's how we got to Lee. What happened is, you know,
比方说鹪鹩的巢。然后它飞走，把它的蛋留给这只鹪鹩孵化。鹪鹩就坐在蛋上直到它孵化，所以鹪鹩最终抚养了这只鸟，也就是另一个物种的幼崽。这就是发生的事情，我们就是这样得到蒂莉的。发生的事情是，你知道，
this little kitten showed up one day on our doorstep. I was away. I came home and my wife had this strange grin on her face. And I thought, you know, I've never quite seen that look. What is that? She had this grin. And she says, come here, come here, come here. And she shows me this lovely little cat. And she says, come here, come here, come here. And she shows me this lovely little cat. And we were hooked. We were hooked. So what do we do? We've been raising Tilly ever since.
有一天这只小猫出现在我们的门廊上。我不在家。我回到家，我妻子脸上带着一种奇怪的微笑。我想，你知道，我从未见过那种表情。那是什么？她带着那种微笑。她说：“过来，过来，过来。”她给我看这只可爱的小猫。她说：“过来，过来，过来。”她给我看这只可爱的小猫。我们迷上了。我们迷上了。所以我们怎么办？我们从那以后一直在抚养蒂莉。
We've basically been consed by Tilly's mom to take care of her nestlings. We don't share any genes with Tilly, but yet the average pet owner over the life of the pet will invest roughly $10,000 in their pet. So we have a $10,000 worth and that's parasite living with this. We get our monies worth out of it. Well you think you get your monies worth because of course it's the parasite that's having the last lap.
我们基本上被蒂莉的妈妈忽悠去照顾她的雏鸟了。我们和蒂莉没有任何基因共享，然而普通宠物在其一生中平均会在宠物身上投资大约1万美元。所以我们有一个价值1万美元的寄生虫和我们生活在一起。我们从这上面物有所值了。嗯，你认为你物有所值，因为当然是寄生虫笑到了最后。
Absolutely. When we come back, how the contradictions and the ways we think about animals lead to paradoxes in how we treat them. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Hal Herzog is a professor of psychology at Western Carolina University. He's the author of the book, some we love, some we hate, some we eat. Why it's so hard to think straight about animals.
绝对的。稍后回来，我们思考动物的方式中的矛盾如何导致我们对待动物方式上的悖论。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。哈尔·赫尔佐格是西卡罗莱纳大学的心理学教授。他是《我们爱谁、恨谁、吃谁：为什么理清对动物的想法如此艰难》一书的作者。
Hal the contradictions in the way we think about animals lead to paradoxes and moral dilemmas in how we treat them. Let's look at the very, very simplest case, millions of Americans like yourself own a cat. They care for their pet, they say they love animals. But you simultaneously say that loving your cat means subjecting other animals to suffering. How so? My cat's a serial killer.
哈尔，我们思考动物的方式中的矛盾，导致了我们在对待它们时出现的悖论和道德困境。让我们看一个最简单、最简单的例子，成千上万像你这样的美国人养了一猫。他们照顾他们的宠物，他们说他们爱动物。但你同时又说，爱你的猫意味着让其他动物遭受痛苦。怎么会这样？我的猫是个连环杀手。
She's an indoor outdoor cat. And so when she wants to go outside I let her outside. And what she does some of the time is kill small animals, sometimes birds, more often it's small mice, voles, creatures like that. I am actually more conflicted by being a cat owner than I am over any other aspect of my relationship with animals. And of course, the cat is doing what comes naturally to the cat. The cat is a predator.
她是一只室内外两用的猫。所以当她想去室外时，我让她出去。她有时做的事就是杀死小动物，有时是鸟，更常见的是小老鼠、田鼠之类的生物。作为一个猫主人，我内心感到的矛盾，实际上超过了我与动物关系的任何其他方面。当然，这只猫在做对猫来说很自然的事。这只猫是一个捕食者。
You can't expect the cat to be behaving any different, but the fact that millions of Americans own cats mean that in some ways they're at least indirectly sanctioning this mass murder of, for example, you know, songbirds. Yeah, and mass murder of, for example, you know, songbirds. Yeah, and mass murder it is, depending on the statistics, somewhere between 1 billion and 5 billion birds each year are killed by our pet cats. Furthermore, cats are obligate carnivores. They have to eat meat. And so I've got lots of friends that are vegetarians and vegans and they're morally opposed to eating meat, but yet they keep cats, and they have to buy animal flesh to keep their cats
你不能指望猫的行为有什么不同，但数百万美国人养猫这一事实意味着，在某种程度上，他们至少是在间接地默许这种对比如鸣禽的大规模屠杀。是的，这就是大规模屠杀，根据统计数据，我们的宠物猫每年杀害的鸟类大约在10亿到50亿只之间。此外，猫是专性食肉动物。它们必须吃肉。因此，我有很多素食主义者和纯素食主义者的朋友，他们在道德上反对吃肉，但他们却养了猫，而且他们必须购买动物肉来维持猫的
happy and healthy. It's a big moral problem for some people. You ran sort of the calculations on this, and you describe them in the book. Mathematically, a cat consumes about two ounces of meat a day. That's about 50 pounds of meat a year. By contrast, snakes only consume maybe five pounds of meat a year. So the impact of having a cat, the moral impact, if you will, is 10 times greater than the moral impact of owning a snake.
快乐和健康。对某些人来说，这是一个巨大的道德难题。你大致计算了一下这方面的账目，并在书中进行了描述。从数学角度来看，一只猫每天消耗大约两盎司肉。这相当于每年大约50磅肉。相比之下，蛇每年可能只消耗大约五磅肉。因此，养猫的影响，也就是道德影响（如果你愿意这么说的话），是养蛇的道德影响的10倍。
And yet, of course, most animal lovers will be horrified if you would suggest replacing kittens with snakes. Or maybe even as we discussed, feeding kittens to walk a snake. Yeah, I actually developed the scale one time I was interested in this issue. And I developed the scale, which I called the feeding kittens to boa constrictor scale. I was actually trying to make fun of psychological skills, but it turned out to produce some very interesting things. So, for example, most of my students that I gave the scale to said that it was okay to feed
然而，当然，如果有人建议用蛇来代替小猫，大多数动物爱好者都会感到惊恐。或者甚至像我们讨论的那样，把小猫喂给蛇吃。是的，有一次我对此产生兴趣时，实际上开发了一个量级。我开发了一个量级，我称之为“喂小猫给蟒蛇吃”的量级。我其实是在取笑心理学量级，但结果却产生了一些非常有趣的东西。所以，比如，大多数我把这个量级拿给他们看的学生都说，可以把
mice to boa constrictors, but it was not okay to feed mice to bulk instructors, but it was not okay to feed mice to cats, which was interesting. And often when I ask them, well, why is it okay to feed mice to a bulk instructor, but not a cat? One of my students put it perfectly. She said, if my cat ate mice, she wouldn't be like me. And that, to me, I can't say this whole thing about what we project onto the animals that we live with.
老鼠喂给蟒蛇，但不能把老鼠喂给猫，这很有意思。而且通常当我问他们：“嗯，为什么把老鼠喂给蟒蛇可以，但喂给猫就不行呢？”我的一个学生回答得非常完美。她说：“如果我的猫吃老鼠，它就不会像我了。”对我来说，这说明了我们投射到与我们生活在一起的动物身上的那种普遍心态。
If my cat ate mice, she wouldn't be like me. Well, she's not like you, girl, you know? But in some ways, bringing sort of cat food home, just like you bring your own groceries home, allows that student in some ways to preserve that illusion, doesn't it? Absolutely. She's preserving the illusion. She's preserving the illusion. Now, if I were a better
如果我的猫吃老鼠，它就不会像我了。嗯，它本来就不像你啊，姑娘，你知道吗？但在某种程度上，把猫粮买回家，就像你把自己的杂货买回家一样，在某种程度上让那个学生得以保留那种幻想，不是吗？绝对是的。她在保留这种幻想。她在保留这种幻想。现在，如果我是一个更好
Person perhaps I would keep my cat indoors, which is a lot of my friends tell me is I should make her an indoor cat well, I resist doing that and My reasoning is probably equally Fulacious is that if I were a cat I would rather be an indoor outdoor cat than a cat that lives in a big cage and spends its day looking outside through the window with the birds flitting around. Now I know that by letting my cat go outdoors, I subject her to the tough things in the wild. In other words, she could get eaten by a coyote. She can't get hit by a car because we live on a road that doesn't have any cars to go down it. But the life of an indoor outdoor cat tends to be shorter, even though she's had a long and good life.
的人，也许我会把猫养在室内，我的许多朋友也告诉我，我应该把它变成一只室内猫。嗯，我拒绝这样做，我的理由可能同样荒谬：如果我是一只猫，我宁愿做一只室内外两栖猫，也不愿做一只生活在大笼子里、整天隔着窗户外面的鸟儿飞来飞去来打发时间的猫。现在我知道，通过让我的猫去室外，我让它面临大自然中的残酷现实。换句话说，它可能会被郊狼吃掉。它不会被车撞，因为我们住的这条路上没有车经过。但室内外猫的寿命往往更短，尽管它度过了漫长而美好的生活。
But I can't completely justify doing that because of the toll she takes on the small animal life. But I live with it. So the more we think of animals as sort of members of our family, the more we think of them as being like us, in some ways this raises a profound moral paradox, does it not, which is that if we actually think of these animals as being like us, how in the world can we, you know, in any good conscience, can find them to our homes, can find them to
但我不能完全为此辩护，因为这会给小动物的生活带来伤亡。但我接受这一点。因此，我们越是把动物视为我们家庭的一员，越是把它们视为像我们一样，在某种程度上这就引发了一个深刻的道德悖论，不是吗？也就是说，如果我们真的认为这些动物就像我们一样，我们怎么可能（你知道的）凭着任何良知，把它们禁锢在我们的家里，禁锢在
cages, treat them as if they were our captives to do with us, we please. Well, I think that's a great point. It's something that I've been thinking about a lot lately. And I've really quite seriously been thinking about, is it ethical to keep animals as pets? If we really think of them as autonomous beings, what right do we have to take away all their autonomy by controlling every aspect of their life? What they eat, where they go, when they go, and increasing work, taking control of their genes, which created its own problems. And so I'm thinking increasingly that I'm wondering
笼子里，把它们当作我们的俘虏来随意对待呢？嗯，我觉得这真是个很好的观点。这是我最近一直在思考的事情。而且我一直在非常认真地思考：把动物当作宠物养合乎道德吗？如果我们真的把它们当作自主的生物，我们有什么权利通过控制它们生活的方方面面来剥夺它们所有的自主权？它们吃什么，去哪里，什么时候去，更严重的是，控制它们的基因，这本身就带来了问题。因此，我越来越开始思考并质疑
about the ethics of keeping animals as pets. To me, the logic of pet keeping is not that different than the logic of meat eating. I eat meat, and I know the arguments against it are good and they're better than my argument for eating meat, which is basically I like the way it tastes. Well, I feel the same way about my cat. I love my cat. But she carries with her a moral burden. And it's my moral burden. It's not her moral burden. I'm the moral agent. I'm the adult in the room, and I'm the one that has to deal with thinking about this stuff. Although most people conveniently repress it and don't think about it.
把动物当宠物养的伦理问题。在我看来，养宠物的逻辑与吃肉的逻辑并没有太大不同。我吃肉，而且我知道反对吃肉的论据很充分，它们比我吃肉的论据要好，我吃肉的理由基本上就是我喜欢它的味道。嗯，我对我的猫也有同感。我爱我的猫。但它随之带来了一个道德负担。这是我的道德负担。这不是它的道德负担。我是道德主体。我是房间里的大人，我是那个必须去处理和思考这些事情的人。尽管大多数人顺理成章地压抑它，不去想它。
You say in the book that you live in what one philosopher calls the troubled middle, and that's what you're talking about here, that you're in some ways you're trying to navigate these contradictions, and it's really impossible to do so with consistency. Yes. One of the things that I've concluded in 30 years of studying human animal relationships as one of my colleagues said, the only consistency about human animal relationships is inconsistency. And I think that I've come to think that this is the human condition. As a psychologist, I study human atom interactions because I think they reveal a lot about the human condition. And so the real subtext of my work in some ways is how do you get out of bed in the morning and get through the day and be a good person.
你在书中说，你生活在一个被一位哲学家称为“充满困惑的中间地带”的地方，这正是你在这里所谈论的，你在某种程度上试图应对这些矛盾，而要做到前后一致真的很难。是的。我在研究人类与动物关系的30年中得出的结论之一是，正如我的一个同事所说，人与动物关系中唯一的一致性就是不一致。我想我开始认为这就是人类的状况。作为一名心理学家，我研究人类与动物的互动，因为我认为它们揭示了很多关于人类状况的信息。因此，在某种程度上，我的工作的真正潜台词是：你如何能在早晨起床，度过这一天，并做一个好人。
I'm wondering how in some ways as you're pointing out, these contradictions are unresolvable. Given the contradictions that you've laid out in the paradoxes of being a pet owner, some of the moral costs that come with being a pet owner, if your current animals were you would have lose them, if they were to die, would you get replacements for them today? Boy, that's a great question. That is such a tough question. I've thought about it. I definitely would not get a dog. I miss having a dog, actually.
我想知道，正如你所指出的，在某种程度上，这些矛盾是不可调和的。鉴于你所列出的宠物主人的矛盾和悖论，以及养宠物所带来的一些道德代价，如果你现在的动物——如果它们要死去的话，你今天还会再去弄新的来替代它们吗？天哪，这真是个好问题。这是一个非常棘手的问题。我想过这个问题。我绝对不会再养一只狗了。其实我很怀念养狗的日子。
My wife and I are both dog people, but we haven't had a dog for 10 years. And it's because our lifestyle doesn't lend itself. I don't think a dog would be happy living in our house because we're away too much during the day. I can't stand the idea of leaving them in a kennel. Our cat's happy to live by herself. And I think the answer is yes. I think the answer is that I would get another cat. The moral dilemmas of pet ownership pale in comparison to the moral dilemmas posed by
我和我妻子都喜欢狗，但我们已经10年没养狗了。这是因为我们的生活方式不允许。我觉得把狗养在我们家里它不会快乐，因为我们白天离开的时间太长了。我无法忍受把它留在狗舍里的想法。我们的猫很高兴独自生活。我想答案是肯定的。我想答案是我会再养一只猫。养宠物的道德困境与
our use of animals in sport and as food. Hal explores some of the deepest contradictions we have toward animals by looking at the sport of cock fighting. First of all, cock fighting is a moral legal now than it was when I was doing that work, but it's just as brutal now. So basically in a cock fight, what you have two chickens, then you have two handlers and you have a referee and a pit, which is roughly 15 feet in diameter. The referee says, pit them, the handlers let them go, and the two roosters try and kill
我们在体育竞技和食物中使用动物所带来的道德困境相比，简直不值一提。哈尔通过观察斗鸡这项运动，探讨了我们对动物最深层的矛盾心理。首先，斗鸡在现在是一个比我当时做这项研究时更不合法的道德问题，但它现在依然同样残忍。所以基本上，在斗鸡比赛中，有两只鸡，然后有两个训鸟人和一个裁判，还有一个直径大约15英尺的斗鸡场。裁判说：“放鸡”，训鸟人把它们放开，然后这两只公鸡试图互相
each other. One rooster almost invariably dies because they have gaffes which are basically knives attached to their legs and it's basically about gambling. There's money changing hands. And so I entered this clandestine world and lived in that clandestine world for a couple of years. Now anyone who hears what you've just described would say, all right, this is morally unconscionable. We cannot allow this to happen. We need to ban this sport, and it has been banned in all parts of the country and many parts of the world.
厮杀。其中一只公鸡几乎不可避免地会死掉，因为它们的腿上绑着刺刀，这基本上是一场赌博。其中涉及金钱交易。于是我进入了这个秘密的世界，并在那个秘密世界里生活了几年。现在，任何听到你刚刚描述的人都会说：“好吧，这在道德上是不可容忍的。我们不能允许这种事情发生。我们需要取缔这项运动。”而且它已经在全国各地和世界许多地方被取缔了。
But tell me a little bit more about what happens when you look more closely at the life of one of these roosters that's raised for cockfighting. And you contrast this in some ways with the life of one of these roosters that's raised for cockfighting. And you contrast this in some ways with the life of your average broiler chicken. Yeah, well, first I want to say that I do not justify cockfighting. Everything you said about it is correct. It is brutal. It is unjustified. It's now banned throughout the United States. And it should be banned throughout the United States. So I'm not trying to justify. For me, as I started studying cockfighters and how they thought I became really interested
但请多跟我讲讲，当你仔细观察这些为了斗鸡而养大的公鸡的生命时，会发生什么？你在某种程度上将这与普通肉鸡的生命进行了对比。是的，嗯，首先我想说，我并不为主张斗鸡辩护。你关于它的所有说法都是正确的。它是残忍的。它是毫无道理的。它现在在美国各地都被禁了。而且它本就应该在美国各地被禁。所以我并不是在为它辩护。对我来说，当我开始研究斗鸡者以及他们的想法时，我变得对
in their moral worlds, and I also began to ask myself some difficult questions. And one of the difficult questions was, if I were a chicken, if I come back in the next world as a chicken, would I rather be at East Tennessee Gamecock or would I rather be a muck nugget? In other words, a chicken raised in a broiler house to become a muck nugget. And to me, there is no doubt in my mind. I would much rather be a gamecock than a chicken destined to be served at McDonald's. Can you describe to me how you reached that conclusion?
他们的道德世界非常感兴趣，我也开始问自己一些棘手的问题。其中一个棘手的问题是：如果我是一只鸡，如果我在来世变成一只鸡，我宁愿做一只田纳西东部的斗鸡，还是宁愿做一块麦乐鸡？换句话说，做一只在养鸡场长大、注定要变成麦乐鸡的鸡。对我来说，我心中毫无疑问。我宁愿做一只斗鸡，也不愿做一只注定要在麦当劳被端上桌的鸡。你能向我描述你是如何得出这个结论的吗？
What is the life of that gamecock and what is the life of that chicken that ends up as a McNugget? Okay, first let's take a gamecock. They live long lives and they live lives that are generally compared to a broiler chicken pretty darn amazing. They live on average two years or not usually fought till they're two years old.
那只斗鸡的生活是怎样的，而那只最终成为麦乐鸡的鸡的生活又是怎样的？好的，我们先来看看斗鸡。它们的寿命很长，而且与肉鸡相比，它们的生活通常可以说是相当惊人的。它们的平均寿命为两年，通常直到两岁时才会被拿去战斗。
For a chunk of their life, they're not usually fought till they're two years old. For a chunk of their life, they live in free range or they have way more room than a broiler chicken. They're fed incredibly well, a very diet, they get plenty of exercise. If they win a couple fights, they will use them as a stud rooster and what they'll do is they'll spend their life chasing the hands around. Not a bad deal. On the other hand, the life of a broiler chicken is absolutely horrendous. Their life only lasts between six and seven weeks. They're
在它们生命中的很大一部分时间里，它们通常直到两岁时才会被拿去战斗。在它们生命的一部分时间里，它们生活在自由放养环境中，或者比肉鸡拥有多得多的空间。它们被喂养得极好，饮食多样，能得到充足的运动。如果它们赢了几场比赛，人们就会用它们作为种公鸡，它们的生活就会变成整天在母鸡后面追逐。这待遇不赖。另一方面，肉鸡的生活绝对是可怕的。它们的生命只有短短的六到七周。它们
basically meat machines, which means that they put on weight so fast that their legs can't really hold up their bodies. And so they have chronic leg pain has been called the world's largest animal welfare problem. They're jammed into giant broiler houses with 30,000 chicks in a broiler house where they'll never see the sun. They'll never get to play on the grass. They'll never get to peck it bugs. Their lungs will be burned with ammonia. It's an absolutely horrendous existence. And they will die at pretty lousy death. They'll be crammed into a series of cages. They'll be hauled for miles and an open truck jammed into small little cages with their feathers
基本上就是肉类生产机器，这意味着它们的体重增长如此之快，以至于它们的腿根本无法支撑它们的身体。因此，它们患有长期的腿部疼痛，这被称为世界上最大的动物福利问题。它们被塞进巨大的养鸡棚里，一个鸡棚里有3万只小鸡，在那里它们永远看不到阳光。它们永远无法在草地上玩耍。它们永远无法啄食昆虫。它们的肺会被氨气灼伤。这是一种绝对可怕的存在。而且它们会死得很惨。它们会被塞进一连串的笼子里。它们会被卡车拉走数英里，塞进开放式卡车上的小笼子里，羽毛
flying down the interstate where they will be hang upside down by their legs, dipped into an electrified water bath to stun them and then they'll go through a carotid artery set of blades that will hopefully kill them quickly although oftentimes it does not. So the life of a gamecock oddly is vastly better than the life of the nine billion chickens that Americans eat each year. I mean that is a billion with a B. You write in the book, while Americans will sleep easy at night
在高速公路上乱飞，在那里它们会被倒挂着抓住双腿，浸入电击水浴中被电晕，然后它们会通过一组颈动脉切割刀片，希望能够迅速杀死它们，尽管通常并非如此。因此，奇怪的是，斗鸡的生活比美国人每年吃掉的90亿只鸡的生活要好得多。我是说，这个“亿”是有B开头的十亿。你在书中写道，当美国人在夜晚安睡时，
knowing cock fighting is banned in all 50 states, 35 million chickens will be stuffed into wire crates on their way to processing plants tomorrow. Yeah, that's in one day. That makes you think, doesn't it? Yeah, absolutely does. When I began doing my research on the comparative cruelty of cock fighting versus mcnuggets, I was stunned.
因为知道斗鸡在所有50个州都被禁止而感到安心，明天将有3500万只鸡被塞进铁丝笼里运往加工厂。是的，那可是一天之内的事。这让人深思，不是吗？是的，绝对是这样。当我开始研究斗鸡与麦乐鸡的残酷性对比时，我惊呆了。
I mean, I was absolutely stunned and I realized, cock fighting should be illegal, but the casual chicken eater is committing a bigger sin in their own way than is the rooster fighter. And by the way rooster fires love their animals. That was one of the things I had to hard time wrapping my head around. It was like, this guy's really love chickens. The comedian Chris Rock once went on David Letterman and talked about some of the contradictions and the way we think about animals. He contrasted the football player Michael Vick who went to prison for promoting dog fighting with the former governor of Alaska
我是说，我绝对惊呆了，我意识到：斗鸡应该是非法的，但随口吃鸡肉的人在某种程度上犯下的罪过，比斗鸡者还要大。顺便说一句，斗鸡者非常爱他们的动物。这是我很难接受的事情之一。我想：“这家伙真的很爱鸡。”喜剧客克里斯·洛克曾在戴夫·莱特曼的节目中谈到我们对待动物的方式中的一些矛盾。他将因涉嫌煽动斗狗而入狱的美式足球运动员迈克尔·维克，与前阿拉斯加州长
and hunting enthusiast Sarah Pillin. She's shooting mooses and she got the moose. Holdin' a dead blooded moose. Michael Vic's like, why am I in jail? LAUGHTER Oh, no! Can that a white lady shoot a moose? Yeah. Black man want to kill a dog.
兼狩猎爱好者莎拉·佩林进行了对比。她在射杀驼鹿，而且她弄到了驼鹿。手里拿着一只血淋淋的死驼鹿。迈克尔·维克却说：“为什么我要进监狱？”（笑声）哦，不！白人妇女射杀驼鹿就可以？对。黑人想杀死一条狗，
That's a crime. It does sound like a double standard, how? Yeah. It does sound like a double standard. We see the same thing in lots of areas of human animal interact. And so, for example, take cock fighting. Cock fighting is a sport of, you know, lower socio- socioeconomic status whites and Hispanics. And on the other hand, compared that with the sport of kings, horse racing.
那就是犯罪。这听起来确实是一个双重标准，哈尔？是的。这听起来确实是个双重标准。我们在人类与动物互动的许多领域都看到了同样的现象。比如，拿斗鸡来说。斗鸡是一项由（你知道的）社会经济地位较低的白人和西班牙裔参与的运动。另一方面，将它与帝王运动——赛马进行比较。
Horse racing is finally coming under the gun. In the last couple of months, as you probably know, I think almost 30 animals were killed at the Santa Anita race track in California. And this has been going on for years and years and years. The number of thoroughbred horses that died. The number is in the thousands and thousands each year. But yet very few people get bent out of shape about horse racing compared to conquiting. So it is a class thing in some ways, isn't it? Very much so.
赛马最近终于受到了抨击。正如你可能知道的，在过去的几个月里，我想大约有30只动物在加利福尼亚州的圣塔安妮塔赛马场丧生。这种情况已经持续了多年。纯血马死亡的数量。这个数字每年高达数千。然而，与斗鸡相比，很少有人对赛马感到大惊小怪。所以在某种程度上，这是一个阶层问题，不是吗？非常是的。
Very much so, it's a class thing. We started this conversation, Hal, by talking about some stories and paradoxes and contradictions from your own life. And I want to end the conversation in the same way When you were in grad school you were once asked to put a number of different creatures into boiling water Why were you asked to do this and walk me through what happened? Yeah, I was working in a chemically collogy lab and we were
非常是的，这是一个阶层问题。哈尔，我们这场对话的开始，是谈论你生活中的一些故事、悖论和矛盾。我想以同样的方式结束这场对话。当你在读研究生时，你曾被要求把几种不同的生物放进沸水中。你为什么被要求这样做？请带我回顾一下当时发生的事情。是的，我在一个化学生态学实验室工作，我们
interested in the chemical perceptions of in in this case, it was reptile snakes, baby snakes, and we basically were interested in whether or not these animals are born with an instinctive preference for certain types of foods. And of course, they eat live animals. So, in this case, there was another researcher in Utah that was interested in doing some more research for his dissertation. And he said, our lab, basically a menagerie, it came in a big box, which basically said this side up, live animals. And the box contained an array of animals, it contained worms, crickets, it contained some scorpions,
对化学感知感兴趣，在这个例子中是爬行动物——蛇、小蛇，我们基本上对这些动物是否天生对某些类型的食物有本能偏好感兴趣。当然，它们吃活的动物。所以，在这个例子中，犹他州的另一位研究员有兴趣为他的博士论文做更多研究。他说，我们的实验室基本上是一个动物园，它用一个大箱子运来，箱子上基本上写着“此面朝上，活体动物”。这个箱子里装了一系列动物，包括蠕虫、蟋蟀、一些蝎子，
it contained a lizard, it contained another snake, it contained, and then a mouse. And so all of the lowest ranking member of the lab, so they assigned me to basically convert these animals to solution. That could be dabbed on a swab and exposed to these snakes. And so the procedure involved dropping these animals into water that was not quite boiling. And I thought, okay, I'll do it. And I dropped the first one in that I think was a cricket and it just died instantly.
它包含了一只蜥蜴，包含另一条蛇，包含了一只老鼠。所以我是实验室里级别最低的成员，因此他们指派我基本上把这些动物转化为溶液。这些溶液可以涂在棉签上，用来对这些蛇进行测试。因此，这个过程包括把这些动物扔进温度接近沸腾的水中。我想，好吧，我来做。我扔进去了第一只动物，我想那是一只蟋蟀，它瞬间就死了。
And then I did the scorpion, which was a bigger animal and it didn't die so quickly. And then I had to do the, as I recall, it was a lizard. And I like lizards, I like reptiles. And it was not good. It took a much longer time for the lizard to die in the water. And I was getting upset. And then I was working my way up the file as you had a scale. And then there was the mouse.
然后我处理了蝎子，它是一只更大的动物，它没有死得那么快。然后我不得不处理——据我回忆——是一只蜥蜴。我喜欢蜥蜴，我喜欢爬行动物。情况不太好。蜥蜴在水里死去的花了很长时间。我开始感到不安。然后我按照你所说的量级逐级向上。接着是老鼠。
It was a cute little mouse. It wasn't a lab mouse. It was one of these cute little wittlin' mice. And I took a look at the mouse. And as I recall, I actually picked it up, was getting ready to drop it in the water, and I just couldn't do it. And I just put the mouse back in his cage,
这是一只可爱的小老鼠。它不是实验鼠。它是那种可爱的小田鼠之一。我看了看这只老鼠。据我回忆，我其实把它拿起来了，正准备把它扔进水里，但我就是做不到。于是我把老鼠放回它的笼子里，
and I went and told the lab manager, I can't do this, somebody else was gonna have to do it. That just haunted me for a very long time. And it really was the event that got me on this journey that I've been on for more than 30 years now about trying to understand why it was so easy to do the cricket and harder to do the lizard and I couldn't do the mouse. And I've never come to grips with it,
然后我去找实验室经理说：“我做不到这个，得换别人来做。”这件事困扰了我很长一段时间。它确实是一起事件，让我踏上了我过去30多年一直在经历的旅程，试图理解为什么处理蟋蟀那么容易，处理蜥蜴难一些，而我却无法处理老鼠。我从来没有真正想通，
but I've been chasing that down. It really is the thing that got me thinking about the psychology of human animal interactions and why we treat some animals different than others. So one way that people justify eating meat and treating animals the way they do is that they believe there's a status hierarchy between animals and it's along the lines of what happened in your lab. So worms are lower on the scale than scorpions. Scorpions are lower on the scale than mice.
但我一直在追寻答案。这确实是让我开始思考人类与动物互动的心理学，以及为什么我们对待某些动物与对待其他动物不同的原因。因此，人们为吃肉和以那种方式对待动物辩护的一种方式是，他们认为动物之间存在地位等级，这与你实验室里发生的情况很吻合。所以，蠕虫在等级上低于蝎子。蝎子的等级低于老鼠。
You once watched the Steven Spielberg movie ET with your daughter and you came up with a thought experiment that probably ruined the movie for her. I actually was my twin daughters. They were both there and probably most listeners are aware of what happens at the end of the movie. So ET and Elliot are running around California, their buddies for, you know, the previous two hours. And at the end, ET's mom comes back to get them and they're flying saucer and ET did that great big head and big eyes. Alex is Elliot and he says he croaks, he goes, come, you know, come with me, we'll go back to Zork and we'll have a great time, you know. And Elliot says, now I can't do anything.
你曾和女儿一起看史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格的电影《外星人E.T.》，并想出了一个思想实验，可能把这部电影在她心中的美好形象给毁了。其实是我的一对双胞胎女儿。她们当时都在场，可能大多数听众都知道电影结尾发生了什么。因此，E.T.和埃利奥特在加利福尼亚四处奔跑，在过去的两个小时里，他们一直是好朋友。在最后，E.T.的妈妈乘着飞碟回来接他们，E.T.转着它那个大大的头和亮晶晶的眼睛。埃利奥特看着E.T.，E.T.用沙哑的声音说：“来吧（你知道的），跟我一起走，我们回佐克星去，我们会玩得很开心（你知道的）。”埃利奥特说：“现在我什么也做不了。”
I guess stay here and ET takes off. And it goes back to Zork and it's all good. And I, my daughter's on the one hand saying, I said, hey, girls, what if ET wanted, Elliot to go back to Zork with them? And so he grabs Elliot and he drags them screaming into the flying saucer because they want to use Elliot in a research experiment.
“我想我得留在这里。”然后E.T.起飞了。它回到了佐克星，一切都很好。然后，一方面我的女儿们在说，我说：“嘿，女孩们，如果E.T.希望埃利奥特和它们一起回佐克星去呢？于是它抓住埃利奥特，把尖叫着的他拖进了飞碟，因为它们想在研究实验中使用埃利奥特。”
They want to use him in an experiment because it's just like this AIDS-like virus and being the people of Zorke. And the Zorkeans are much smarter than Americans. They're much smarter than Elliot. Would it be okay for ET to kidnap Elliot and take him and use them in biomedical research experiment? And my kids are horrified. No, dad, no, no.
它们想在一个实验中使用他，因为这就像是一种类似艾滋病的病毒，而佐克星人是这样的。佐克星人比美国人聪明得多。他们比埃利奥特聪明得多。E.T.绑架埃利奥特，把他带走并用在生物医学研究实验中，这可以吗？我的孩子们感到惊恐万分。不，爸爸，不，不。
And I thought the same thing, no, that would not be a good idea. But on the other hand, what I realized was that our use of animals in biomedical research is based on the same premise. You know, we're smarter than other creatures. We're way smarter than mice. We're way smarter than dogs. We're somewhat smarter than chimpanzees in our own ways. And that's our justification for using animals than mice were way smarter than dogs, were somewhat smarter than chimpanzees in our own ways.
我也这么想，不，那可不是个好主意。但另一方面，我意识到的是，我们在生物医学研究中使用动物是基于相同的前提。（你知道的）我们比其他生物更聪明。我们比老鼠聪明得多。我们比狗聪明得多。在某些方面，我们比黑猩猩稍微聪明一些。这就是我们使用动物的理由——比老鼠聪明得多，比狗聪明得多，在某些方面比黑猩猩稍微聪明一些。
And that's our justification for using animals in biomedical research. And I was fortunate to conclude that, look, we're going to use animals in research. We got let ET take Elliot back to Zork and use them in a cage. Obviously it's the same sort of thought experiment that I did when I concluded we out of feed kittens to bokeh and stricters, you know. But I still can't wrap my head around that. My heart's telling me one thing, even though logic is telling me something else. And that's just of a lot of our inconsistencies with our interactions with animals.
这就是我们在生物医学研究中使用动物的理由。我很幸运地得出结论：听着，我们要把动物用在研究中。我们得让E.T.把埃利奥特带回佐克星，把他关在笼子里做实验。显然，这和我得出“我们必须把小猫喂给蟒蛇吃”时所做的思想实验是同一种类，你知道的。但我还是无法理解这一点。我的内心在告诉我一件事，尽管逻辑在告诉我另一件事。这正是我们与动物互动的许多不一致之处的一个缩影。
Hal Herzog is a professor of psychology at Western Carolina University. He is the author of the book, some we love, some we hate, some we eat. Why it's so hard to think straight about animals. Hal, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, thanks for having me, Animals and Us, from Psychology Today. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Parth Shah, Laura Quarrell and Jenny Schmidt.
哈尔·赫佐格是西卡罗来纳大学的心理学教授。他是《我们爱一些，我们恨一些，我们吃一些：为什么很难理性思考动物》一书的作者。哈尔，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，谢谢邀请我，来自《今日心理学》的“动物与我们”。本周的节目由托马斯·刘制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩剪辑。我们的团队包括帕思·沙、劳拉·夸雷尔和珍妮·施密特。
For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like today's show, please remember to share it with one friend. We're always looking for new people to discover Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vidantam, see you next week. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，你可以在脸书和推特上找到我们。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请记得分享给一位朋友。我们一直在寻找新面孔来发现《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，我们下周见。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。